oh hello y'all I think good way to start
off a presentation today I'm gonna be
talking to you about the history of
running frameworks there's actually room
I feel it's pretty important talk
because I'm presenting only because the
material that I would be going over
today really does help it helps explain
shape explain why things are the way
they are now in JavaScript you know like
I'm assuming there are some developers
out there that go on Stack Overflow and
and you know as you're looking for the
answer they see jQuery they're like
what's jQuery how does that fall into
react or you know they talk about state
like what is state like how I'm hoping
tonight will be able to I'll be able to
explain that and help answer some of
those questions you may have so first of
all why do I think the used to react
meetup group or allow me to present
tonight I also want to thank y'all for
coming out the last thing that I want is
for someone in this room to walk away
thinking that you know man how's it make
some time I really I try to or I made
this presentation with the mindset that
though there you know many types of
developers in this room from you know
developers that are self learning
developers are currently in boot camps -
you know developers have been doing this
for decades now so I really feel bad
people or everyone here will walk away
with something
no they're I guess another housekeeping
or just want to tell you all tonight we
are recording tonight's presentation so
in case that you missed something or if
you want to follow up on some of the
topics I'm going to be talking about
know that I will be posting it on the
meetup group either later on this
weekend or maybe in tonight I don't know
yet make sure go over everything and
then also since I don't think a lot to
make sure we can hold all questions to
the end just so that way we can kind of
have at the Q&A group discussion on some
of the questions y'all may have with
that let's get started
presentation there we go
so as I mentioned my name is Peyton
winds hello plot twist
I'm actually an iOS developer at Taiwan
yeah
all of y'all so at Taiwan's hearing the
super digital innovation agency we
worked with multiples of our clients are
in the enterprise space and what's
really cool is because I work on those
type of projects I come across some
really interesting problems that a lot
of people that have you know after the
building the developers won't come
across so things like you know some of
the topics he'll be talking today things
like architectures things you know those
topics are before I didn't know anything
about it now I'm very very comfortable
uncomfortable with them and then also
okay so as far as my loves JavaScript
Swift and actually only couldn't be a
spacebar twice but this is gonna be a
Ben Stiller themed presentation I want
to have some fun with it and so I felt
you know earlier this week I came across
the Ben Stiller gif don't like yes this
is what I want to happen and
presentation like I could really make a
storyline with Ben Stiller isn't that
it's not that he's my favorite actor or
anything just have some really funny
movies so hopefully you know if you
don't walk away with something with the
presentation you would least walk away
blind to see one of these movies right
something I like each one more time
there you go so some of the questions
you might be asking yourself what is
Ajax what estate mean what is this thing
people say it's NBC what is that I don't
know why are there so many frameworks
and then also this atlas stripped the
how does all this tie in together so you
have some of those questions great I'm
really hope that I answer them and if
not I have two words like matcha they
might provide you the tools so you don't
find those answers so let's go over our
agenda really first foremost what is
JavaScript
and why why does it exist
they were talked about before but before
time and now we're to be talking about
web versions Atmos cribs the browser
Wars it's a really interesting battle
captain you know took place in the mid
90s mid night to the early 2000s a lot
of casualties then afterwards we're
going to talk about the before time and
then it's going to be talking about
server-side rendering and client-side
rendering now one thing I want to
mention the material that we're going to
be going over in these two sections are
in no particular order it's just
information that you need to have that
just because you know whoever's just
before techno script doesn't mean that
it happened before it's just you know
information that you need that would
block for the audience to know before we
get to our next section which is the
framework era all right
so I really had some fun with the this
section here and I realized like we have
we had all these battles with Wars in
between these frameworks right and if no
one gives them a name like I'm going to
now I'm gonna do whatever I want to call
them right so I'm gonna call the first
war first blood right this is going to
be your jquery's your move tool dojo
then someone cannot think of art you can
already think of what the next war is
gonna be the mana Oh kind of got cut off
there but it's the UH
the monolithic mailing I try to have you
know some some fun with them and then
last is going to be the clash of the
components so these are all Wars right
now we're currently in the third floor I
don't know if you know this but the
first two happened and if you missed it
don't worry I'm gonna recap what you
missed out on all right and then after
that what's next like okay baby we just
have these three Wars we're in the
middle third one I'm tired what's coming
down the pipeline this is actually going
to be my opinion so as I mentioned a few
slides ago and iOS developer so of my
opinion I don't really have a lot of
weight behind it but from my
observations what I've seen I do I kind
of have an idea
we're going next we're going to have to
follow up topics these are just going to
be this is gonna be a slide that's gonna
everything I talked about briefly along
with names some videos there were some
must watch videos if you're a JavaScript
developer especially react developer and
then lastly we're going to be going
we're going to have questions sound good
so first what is JavaScript and why so
it was created in 1995 by Brennan I say
his name
it worked at Netscape it was developed
in ten days think about what you did ten
days ago or think about what's I what's
ten days from now it's going to be
whether not this Sunday the next or next
two Saturdays from now measured you
create an entire language so next time
someone starts you know bashing on
JavaScript say hey I want to know how
well the language you could have made
ten days right
next thing Netscape and Sons lab joined
forces and gets Microsoft so look why
this is important is remember Brendan
Brendan you worked for Netscape right
and so right now this was happening
during the early browser wars we had a
good Microsoft Internet Explorer
Netscape got a few other browsers and
they're all pretty much fighting for you
know what's gonna be the main browser a
little bit they know this thing of
chrome was gonna be coming out later but
right now they have no idea right so
they're all fighting so Netscape and
sons lab giving them back that they're
much smaller than Microsoft they
actually joined forces like okay hey we
needed to have we need to have this up
this is actually the up the next slide
so why was it made to make me to make a
browser interactive right
and so they joined forces to look create
JavaScript result sure was created here
and then they later join some apps you
know kind of join the cause on okay
let's let's see plain JavaScript like
this is both we're going with this is
where we're putting all our Easter eggs
and let's go with Docs that's the only
way we're gonna build to compete compete
with Microsoft and whatever you know
monster they come out with right so by
the way this this all looks foam anomaly
this really should be its own tautness
reason why I'm briefly going over it
like I couldn't spend another two hours
talking about it just knows a lot of
information don't worry the names for
you to look into like read in and then
another one don't worry it's gonna be
later on in the slides but this is
really really interesting what happened
here I'll go everyone should know this
but don't worry for today just know a
few these items right like this
connection right here Sons lab clean
ownership of the JavaScript trademark so
why is that important well this is why
the standard spot atmospheric and not
JavaScript so I mean you really yes by
yes six yes evident the reason why it's
not J is spotted JavaScript blonde
JavaScript five dollar scripts six I can
we got like Ruby one groovy two Swift
one swift to write so because Suns lad
had claimed ownership of it whenever
that skating went to standardize the
language well ended up at the European
computer manufacturer a European
computer manufacturers association don't
where they said there's some things to
be able to learn later time fortunately
and they can apologize strip and so they
ended up falling on the decision that
like we don't let's call it Atmos true
and so for the longest time me as a
JavaScript developer I'm like let is yes
probably I've been doing JavaScript also
we're talking with this script like what
is it it's the same exact thing but you
must not mix JavaScript
ichael script Jace Jace crib all the
same thing trademarks reason why you
can't call it your script I don't know
what it is now like that's still the
case but that's reason why we are where
we are now so this is a bit of a
timeline don't worry you know what's
going on here oh but just know you know
from 1999 all the way to leave up it
goes down to 2016 a lot happens here
right Soviet Lee the creation of some of
these browsers as well as some
frameworks you know html5 angular is
somewhere there and I saw earlier we
have rails a jQuery here over here in
2006
so just know there's a lot that's going
on by the way that right now we're kind
of like circling this area here right
but just up keep in mind 2006 system
that's a pretty important year for a
JavaScript developer so just keep that
aback your mind so before the before
time right like I said this is these are
some items that aren't in any particular
order you just accept these are just
this is just material that I would like
for you to know before using the
framework era so web 1.0 what that means
no dynamic content you know that means
the word but 2.0 will explain that I
didn't know what it meant
javascript and CSS are still you know
little babies they don't really have
they still don't know who they all what
they do really had the major players or
did that escape and Internet Explorer
and to give you some context I'll bet
you're trying to wonder like what was I
doing in 1990 or like bolus of bulls
happening
what can I kind of like you know attach
myself with and remember when felt like
to be in 1990s low around this time Ben
Stiller was filming happy gilmore so
okay see you next time you see this
movie just remember oh hey wellpoint Oh
Ellis at the same time so the next one
with 2.0 right so it added dynamic HTML
it means JavaScript and CSS can
manipulate the Dom like cool like that
that's react in a nutshell really right
so this is in the early 2000s
drag-and-drop animation you know some
examples are gonna be like Amazon
Wikipedia YouTube so this was in the
2000 right so you can kind of member
like okay what can I attach myself to
remember like oh this is when when to
point okay now well this one Starsky and
Hutch came up alright so there's some
you see that movie really takes place
from the 70s right where it's the 60s
thanks Evan just know that
oh but 2.0 was around this thing you
don't run the same time so this is now
okay I said nothing's in any particular
order
it's just information that I needed to
bring to your attention so ECMO strip
right so now we got this really really
cool edits I didn't
learn this while doing research for this
presentation so V 3 1999 right the war
does a reason why you don't hear es 4
right I don't ever look looked into it
but it doesn't exist it was abandoned
actually right so then happy 5 and 2009
look how there's a 10-year gap here
right look at these look at the date I'm
starting to make summer 2006 right like
all these think detective here right V 5
2009 5.1 2011 this is actually pretty
important as well you don't need to use
the use strict in your JavaScript that's
actually the standard that they fall on
wears to me it falls on version 5.1 that
standard so some of the muggy parts of
JavaScript that they really want to do
away with actually it's you know gets
cleared here in 5.1
then you have b6 b7 be any kind of known
from there but there's all this es stuff
right so remember it's echo strip only
because Sons lab had the trademark to
the you know have the JavaScript
trademark so whenever they had to create
a standard for it that I okay we'll just
call it necklace strip very confusing
Michael I didn't learn until I did this
presentation so then now okay lots of
information that you know right remember
those days I was talking about right now
listen to the browser Wars right and so
this graph actually ends in 2008 which
is when chrome was created up but you
can kind of know what happened from
there as far as you know who's winning
or who started winning from there but
let's let's up not like the line I
couldn't find one that had in 1994 the
nineties all the way to today so I had
to just you know and this was more
important at the time of course so just
so it does make chrome got created
things change again but uh okay this is
the timeline from 1994 to you 2008 right
we look back this is time 99 2009 right
things are trying to up timelines are
starting to line up here right so
this is what I found very interesting
I'm gonna go and read it to you have you
ten years in which nothing happened
allow for the language to become stable
Douglas Crockford that's what he was
talking about was this right here no
sock called browser Wars right what was
happening that was all these browsers
you know Firefox Internet Explorer
Netscape they're still figuring things
out especially in the JavaScript world
especially now okay default browser
compatibility was bad now that veil was
worse what would have made things ten
times worse is if we had new versions of
JavaScript as these browsers are trying
to you know figure things out and try to
make things compatible right so it was
good it's great that we didn't have a
ps4 because that would have I don't even
know but it happens Mike you might have
been right in the front end in Java or C
or something I don't know but just know
that you know these browser wars in the
ECMO strip it all concise it together
just motivated to work on JavaScript
during this time there's just the
headache it's good so now okay that was
some information right like I said you
just need it to know that as we're
getting into the this section with the
next oh so now we're at the beforetime
so before time I want to think we're not
the frameworks yet we're not a jQuery
we're just in vanilla JavaScript right
so some terms I want you to know our
server-side rendering and client-side
rendering so a server-side rendering you
ought to existed I'm gonna explain these
two salt serves I'm going to be
logically existed on the backend it's
very expensive I want you to think of
you can rewind the clocks real quick to
you know early myspace days or late
myspace basically Facebook days where
you know you're standing there your
profile and your wait for you know a new
notification and you're like okay
command arm let me refresh it right also
in bloom you have a new comment or
something right but if you wouldn't have
seen it unless you refreshed it right
that's server-side rendering and that
means all everything that you see on the
screen doesn't actually is actually
being computed or created on the server
the server that fits that to your
browser right then you applied side
rendering client-side the logic exists
on the client this is what we are
experiencing now this will react angular
move all that to where you check to see
okay it's user logged in user logged in
let me show them this people is a user
not logged in okay I'm gonna show them
the login screen that used to happen on
the server
now what happens on the client 3 small
is expensive let's pretend you know you
have your little your little website
that unfortunately is just you and your
mom that visit right that's not really
that expensive but if you think about
Facebook or some of these major new
YouTube they did server-side rendering
and magic having to spit up from
millions of requests and every single
day you know entire webpage it's pretty
expensive so sweet want a client-side
exists so I said this this is going to
come into play later this is going to
this important when we start talking
about Ajax so we have them a meetup
example or may an example to kind of
illustrate this so in here we have a
bootstrap template I had any let's
pretend this is a social network that
you're building right this is your your
accounts page where you've updated your
username or something like that I don't
know right and it also needs a sidebar
and you see they'll get in at vagin you
don't hear that violets my twitter
handler give up that's how you contact
me probably should content slide sorry
in Vegas here on the sidebar in the you
know the body the main content and also
the nav bar over there on the far right
like I in it Fabian kind of see that
sometimes right so we have it throughout
the web page right it's a server-side
rendering
that's purchase so this just makes you
know don't worry like I don't you if you
can imagine what you know what it is a
point in that and that's why I just know
that this is a span of the class of user
name info why this is important is for
later on but I just want to say like
okay this is hard-coded in the you know
in the p-tech like my name rank so this
is server-side render will end up
happening is when you hit update of the
floor
just right here think of an HTML form
right just before client-side rendering
whenever you hit the submit or update
would end up happen is it's the form get
sent up to the server and then the
server responds back with that hey you
forgot to fill in this field so if
you've experienced when you're you know
when you're filling out like a 10 field
you know for I'll like to sign up or
something or the like probably
government forms when you whenever this
happens and then also you can submit all
the page refresh is in a smaller air box
says hey forgot to you know fill in zip
code and all your text fields are in you
gotta do it all over again
that's server-side rendering that's
what's gonna happen here we're never
ended up dating it's gonna go up to the
server serves gonna spit back you know
an HTML page and if it's up if it
updates my name it's gonna update in all
three locations you know sidebar the the
main body of the navbar
so now let's talk ok now let's talk
about client-side rendering so we have
the XML HTTP request
they said this is straight from vanilla
JavaScript I mean do story I've never
actually was able to make this work
whenever I was when I was learning
JavaScript and I didn't know what jQuery
looks or you know what bootstrap is
right I you know I just saw this and I'm
following this of these the new bosses
tutorial never give it to work to save
my life come to those browsers or what
but I end up you know just oh let me
just copy this jQuery bang and oh they
have this Ajax when we're talking about
that later but just know that yeah this
is going to be this is a vanilla
JavaScript at its best
so xmlhttprequest aka Ajax it stands for
asynchronous JavaScript and XML
that's an ajax transport I have actually
never parsed if a XML file on my line
but that's what stands for it's actually
misleading this was on w3 school Ajax is
that Miss sleep isn't misleading name
Ajax applications might use XML to
transport data but it is equally common
to transport data as plain text or Jason
so just it's in misleading name Ajax is
all you really gotta know like I said so
what Ajax allowed us to do it's going to
talk about that is it allow
communicate to a server without having
to refresh the entire page so whenever
you hit submit we can instead do instead
of having to submit the entire form you
can just hit this option here we can
communicate to the server or to the URL
just right now here and we can pass in
all this mumbo-jumbo oh you only need to
know what's going on to smell the okay
it's a vanilla JavaScript age I get it
you know I'm embarrassed
this is what it looks like another thing
to know of Safari
did not admit this is where remember
those bait I was talking about it's hard
to implement this until you know one
point two thousand two thousand four
opera did it and operating 2005 and
Internet Explorer did in 2006 right so
let's see it accepts once you remember
those dates all right so now get this
form again right so now with our vanilla
JavaScript you hit update we can instead
do you just run this JavaScript function
with this JavaScript function we do is
to communicate to the server hey is this
it's okay to update their name right and
the services okay yes here's the updated
name and then and one of these functions
down here
it's like line six they can see it what
I do is I get the element my class name
username info and I set the inner HTML
to the updated username that's all I get
and so that would been updated
throughout my entire application cool
right now let's talk about the framework
era so where things start getting juicy
really juicy so this is just a timeline
I want to show you right dates again 9
2016 8 Murray comes out right remember
all those timelines all those dates tell
the station where the magic happened I
don't know where all that took office
things to be honest I think I was in
middle school but I know it wasn't
nowhere near keyboard to develop
anything you know I have the rest but I
just want to show you just a timeline
that exists so the framework era what is
a framework
so it's a library it's all it is it's a
way to help you organize applications
right imagine P does have a framework
that you did it your own way with
vanilla JavaScript when you came to
looked at my applications and I did it
my own way things look very different
you wouldn't know what's going on so
fortunately frameworks allow us to have
some sort of you know common ground you
know we standardized saturda zation help
collaborate and more importantly this is
a really good point cross-platform
compatibility as you put your element
before jQuery if you wrote your own
website you means making API requests
when all those other browsers did it
implement the HTTP or XML HTTP request
you could have a lot of trouble right so
having frameworks allow doesn't have
that cross-platform one else work on all
the browsers
I made code more reusable right it was
really nice to just be able to go to you
know your own project or on some Stack
Overflow and even though if it existed
yet and just copy the answer and casing
boom it worked right so that's what
frameworks allowed us to do and then
also allow us to build out communities
and have some great tutorials it's
really hard to learn you have to learn
how to do some of these things without a
framework source name JavaScript because
you go to lots of torts and we don't
love waiting to go to another one we've
done separate win so it's I so
experience that today especially when I
was like learning note but it's another
day so now we're in our first battle
right you've made it this far
first blood doesn't come out smooth but
this is a topic Thunder this is ben
stiller he's drawn first blood right
he's having some fun with this machine
gun so let's choose a side yeah
prototype
yeah dojo you have tools and then jQuery
spoiler alert jQuery wins we're not
going to talk about all that mature talk
about jQuery I don't care about losers
just jQuery so jQuery
released in 2006 the dates simplified
JavaScript tasks things such as you know
applying styles animations Dom
manipulation and then more importantly
age
like if you can think about serving per
line side rendering it ok the
xmlhttprequest that it really happened a
lot until Jake burger came out alright
and so when we saw jQuery as a developer
I didn't see I've gone assuming when the
jobs were developers all the time when
they saw they probably thought that's
blues field right
this thing is magic so it's not about HX
right it's all the other stuff you can
already know what's going on especially
we do and react like it what you see
it's influenced heavily by jQuery so
this is really like the grandfather of
it all so let's talk about Ajax remember
the splitter look like really really
ugly I really don't want to see this
that's what it turned into that looks
very similar to what you're used to like
in please pronounce axiom I never used
it but I'm just what you see in you know
HTTP with node you see the dollar sign
HTTP in angular so this event very
influential to all the future frameworks
moving forward so next time Saul wants
to challenge going something you just
bring that up even if it's irrelevant
you're talking about cats or the feed
all the rockets just point this may be
like look this is what I know what do
you know so jQuery another important are
the events really said this really did
shape frameworks moving forward so but
this is is this pound that we have here
in front of us it's it's an ID on an
HTML element you know I would say
whenever this element submits I want you
to run this function so if this was a
for all your putting ID on it you could
attach this listener very soon to what
we see now and so here if you can get
the value set up doing get element by ID
put in the ID you got inner HTML at
vanilla JavaScript that turns into this
right here dollars you know how updated
user name field Val boom you got your
input and put a text field and we're
just console logging it well let's
combine the two let's combine that event
listener that we just saw and also menu
Ajax
that turned the code into this it's
really really small like I said you
really don't have to know exactly what's
wrong
slides traditionally beat uploaded
afterwards really kind of small but just
oh it really struck down it really
shrunk down in uniform and made it very
reusable moving forward then peace was
brought to the galaxy always well we're
like okay we're done like man that was a
brutal battle but the internet seems
like it's going it's not gonna be
changing anytime soon
right and then the monolithic melee
happened a lot of people were lost but
it's not really getting shot this film
on topic all if you can imagine all my
war scenes are from Tropic Thunder
unfortunately but they just really
exaggerated the amount of times you got
shot you've got like ten more times
before this so when we start talking
about the actual frameworks you're
something you know there's a top it
doesn't need to go over it's a call MVC
actually been coming from iOS I deal
with MVC a lot and so let's kind of bias
for me to be up here some kind of one
side I just like it so many ways protect
you too near that and we're gonna talk
about all the frameworks like the rest
of the world saw them when they were
released you know the golden you know
silver bullets that they all work so NBC
it's an architectural pattern not a
design pattern these are some topics is
these are uh the material I want to look
into later on or whatever you're bored
like okay I want to know about something
cool and not programming our potential
patterns design pattern two very
different things
so architectural patterns are way for
you to separate your codebase in in this
case into either models views or
controls it needs to fall under one of
those three classes or one of those
three components things like services
you have all these others but NBC
states that you will have a model and
you and a controller and the way that
information flows through them it's not
very clear don't worry we'll get into
that later but just know whenever the
JavaScript developers all the time saw
that and like wow this is amazing if
you've had jQuery
right but whenever I want to store user
you know use your email or use your full
name course information or state of
user I don't have anywhere to store it
like I'd be really nice for me to have
things like you know such a thing as a
model or controller for me to like be
able to separate my coat and away to
where I can store user information you
know over here and be able to manipulate
the DOM and you know pump different our
pump my data into the view you know all
you know with yeast instead of doing it
jQuery way
jQuery like say there's more utilities
to review to manipulate the Dom it
really wasn't made to maintain users
stay or to be able to handle user and
state management or Satan it's not good
for state management so another term for
you to look into later on so NBC it
helped with a separation of concerned
either somebody's programming some
programming jargon or you know buzzword
and so it just means that your code
really should be separate into a
presentation layer a business layer or a
data layer right if it doesn't fall in
one of those three then you're doing
something wrong that's what every C
really likes to say in some way but I
don't agree with it don't worry Redux
and all that ang is it don't worry
make sure I cover everything and so by
the way this make sure okay so you want
to make sure that your views and your
controllers and your models are not are
not typing couple of meaning if I were
to copy this controller and paste it in
this other project that it's not going
to complain or don't ever say like hey I
don't know what this model that you're
talking is that you're talking about
right so they really MVC it's it really
wants you to decouple your code but
because isn't necessarily the case so
let's choose a side so over in the
monolithic Frank up the monolithic melee
here so we got backbone Jas got ember we
got angular there's a few others but
these bird you know for the most part
were the three big players right and the
developers at the time all thought this
is all blue steel gear all right this
this is what we're looking for so let's
use an example is using to-do lists I
mean whenever you learn a new language
one of the first thing that you do is
created to do to be Lestat so we're
going to break down this app as a as NBC
so for sure we know that our entire
website our entire view like that is a
view right so therefore because we have
a view here we need to have a controller
we need to have a model even if we drive
anything in it you need to happen right
so we have a few Indian government
roller for the parent class then we also
have an NBC here with the to-do list so
we actually couple is and that means
okay we how we're gonna have a list is
gonna have table right and we're just
gonna feed it in a model an array of two
do's and it's going to display it on
interview and then lastly be able to do
write to do will have its own view which
is gonna be a row it's gonna have its
own controller to build handle you know
the delete on the right hand side or the
is complete on the left hand side so
like NBC all the way down right it looks
moving organized like it looks good like
it but I can build this you know your
spec with MVC and I don't think I'm
breaking any kind of any Co conventions
or any walls right but baby about the
thing about MVC that you need to know is
or the term I mentioned separation of
concerns and also there's another term
called single responsibility principle
what it means is your code should only
be showing in charge of all functions
using should only be in charge of one
thing that's it right so we have the
main or you have an app controller it's
controller the entire app right but does
it have control over the over the items
inside of the list controller right it
only needs to worry about the entire
view any anything anything that happens
there right and so as you as you get
smaller and smaller than to do
controller the actual row should not
communicate back up to its parent or the
to do list controller should not
communicate down or up they you should
just have instead single responsibility
principle probably this solid
programming term I forget with
that's something for you to look into
later if you want
so let's look at how all these
frameworks are doing so this is backbone
it doesn't actually follow MVC so sorry
I'd like to you
there's no controllers you have the
model you have a view / controller but
already a red flag kind of you know Rick
leg gets thrown up with the events where
we go on line four
it's a view look at line one backbone
dot view dot extend right then you have
events meaning this view is handling
event which as we as we remember a view
should only be single responsibility
principle should only be responsible for
displaying the data and that's it the
controller should be in charge of
handling events and how he shouldn't you
take the view or if it needs to update
the model it's already you know this is
going on okay okay
the developers other time didn't know
that that's fine as an iOS developer I
know this
hey MVC we deal with this all the time
actually an iOS MVC stands for massive
view controller so it's kind of funny
how we just kind of throw everything in
the controller that's a real thing you
google it you will find it so now let's
talk about effort Cooper by Bart is the
closest to MPC so beyond the model you
know the you it actually uses handlebar
JSTOR render out its views and so it
just means allows you to put JavaScript
inside of your X amount work inside your
HTML through the other controller
section looks really good I don't have
anything bad to say I don't have to need
experience with backbone or ember
angular I do let's look what I see it
it's actually pretty good
we have angular I think they have I
afford to agree act I had done angular
from probably ot like three years I made
all my websites I even made a website
for a client angular and I'm looking to
you know change that to real to react
but up so what made annular interesting
is that two-way data-binding I don't
necessarily know backbone and ember had
the out of the box
at least the
that angular did but what it meant is
let's go to text field and you're
inputting information and you had a
label where it's gonna beat your head up
you know ap tag you know some text over
here you can set up your controller to
wear whatever you type inside the text
field via the label or the text on the
other side will update that was really
cool I wrote when I first saw that like
that is awesome I love angular not
really knowing what was gonna happen
later on because we didn't have a simple
to-do list that that's all that's that's
gold once you get into a real life
application which we will in a bit
you're gonna see how that backfires
pretty quick something about angular I
know if anyone here has experience with
it or those who don't so this was
another thing that I didn't know you
know a lot of doctors didn't know the
problem in time so this is Mike to do
right it's open pretty open bracket my -
to do snake case right well that's how
you use it right and this is the
directive dissipation but this is the
component that you're used to seeing and
react right isn't just so you some small
bit of HTML and whenever you call if you
use you know this HTML element it's just
gonna replace it's gonna replace this
with that sorry I don't why it took me
so long to say but this is and so now in
order your JavaScript to know that it
exists you need to have a directive and
with this tell us with this so the
JavaScript programs like hey you're
gonna have a file on my father says it's
gonna be to do dot TPL dot HTML simple
TV else my own personal preferences I
like to sub sub categorize my my my
files so it knows that it's looking for
that file and remember how this is my -
to do well over here on line - it's
actually camel case double small the
worst things in angular that I felt like
I always whenever directed or a
component didn't you know show up on the
view the very first thing is probably
messed up on my name because in
JavaScript it needs to be camel kicks
but in HTML it needs to be snake case
that was the worst thing and then would
suck
whenever I was built back to angular how
it was for kid and I would just be going
into Stack Overflow then realizing
complaintants later that like oh you do
that and then finally of a controller if
you see there is no model it's and
there's no models which is confusing
controllers and at the time I don't
really know what NBC was so I didn't
really know supposed to have it but if I
was going into angular today I would
think to myself where do I store my data
there's a huge learning curve
I remember that I would fight against my
angular programs or felt like so I weeks
until finally things started clicking
you start learning things - angular
width and then so views are just a lot
of work so of the three or assuming of
the four street seat here three of them
belong to just feeling yeah I do all
this just for you I didn't know what
that was a lot of work at the time I had
just you know I just learned what jQuery
was yeah that was angular so let's do a
real-world application right so let's
just disregard the names just say okay
amber back column angular right and
these were when I say monolithic
frameworks what I meant is that these
are all on one solution for you okay
I mean it would react react very good
about like oh if you want to use jQuery
with react you can work it can work in
angular it can work with just regular
plain vanilla JavaScript but with these
other frameworks for example with meteor
with meteor if you have meteor project
if you want to use something I'm just
going to throw a framework under the
bustard let's say you want to use
underscore right you needed to find me
under the meteor version of underscore
you'd always mean you could just throw
in any JavaScript class or some any
JavaScript library and with your
non-olympic framework oh I remembered I
would annular if you've had jquery
things broke all the time so robot
application right so we're going to the
mini code right so let's break down this
this example using empty MVC
architecture so just completed setter we
have wanted you to see here right so we
have to be to the main body then we have
another PCB on the sidebar right so
we can handle my name here let's say the
spreads had like infrared the season it
said like oh you have four hundred
friends right so it control them get out
of controller for all this information
that I controller for all this
information here indeed in the main body
oh and then also we need a controller
for the nav bar too right so I arguable
like I was able to slip up my
application into these section and it
looks it looks good yeah well okay well
now let's let's go to implement some of
the code for me to update the tech
support update the username right no
models remember that okay when I hit
update it updates it here but oh wait
look I'll see the problem I need an
update over here this controller and
also the nav bar but then that breaks
our single responsibility principle W
dimension earlier like I did controller
shooting communicates other controllers
and shouldn't communicate up so it lets
it we had a parent controller around
this disc until we should not
communicating back to the parent for the
parent vent tubes helping other
introduced already we're in a bad spot
really okay you know what all right fine
I'm gonna do this one time four hours
later you're gonna do about ten more
times and two months later you're going
to be coming across some code or you
come across a bug you know how does this
even happen now I'm realizing that you
have this thing called side effects that
are happening in your code you updated
here also you have a side effect on the
other side of your application that
updates and you're just like I don't
know where this book came from so this
is this is the problem that you have
that you come across with MVC specially
in JavaScript especially with iOS so
let's rewind quick during this while
you're developing this application and
your MVC Model View framework the
thinking you you like this you having
fun
everything is awesome everything is
groovy right not really knowing what
you're doing is this you just you just
set yourself up to fail so bad like as I
did with my angular application that is
gasoline now on the next scene is when
things go up in flames but they didn't
have a gift that had all of them
so else I would have put it okay so the
issue is to go back controller to get
bloated because really there in between
the models and the views so my nature
you want to just like oh we just throw
this in this controller not really
thinking that like oh it really needs to
be somewhere else but wait it needs
either be a model of you or controller
so I kinda don't know where to put this
things like oh I need to make a pre-baby
I call to you know send up you know
analytics or something right as soon as
you do that broke the single
responsibility principle you should your
controller to only control what it is
because classified so or whatever
component it is a charge up but oh also
data bindings data bindings bad at least
for me every single time someone says
like absorbable to me to colonies gives
me a uh you know I start getting this
pain affect my neck my girl observables
is not a bad word or anything and it's
still used very much today there's very
valid use cases but I just automatically
think about two-way data-binding and I
just remember you know the headaches
that came with that but don't like that
discouraging little baby I followed the
diagram like well how come it's not
working well is NBC if you remember the
photo that saw earlier Alice's top one
look at the arrows way they're
communicating is one way right you can
look at these other ones these are still
NBC pattern as you can kind of see there
really is no set standard on how how
your application communicates between
your model is refusing your controllers
so for example this view actually
observes the model and it communicates
back to the controller but then also the
controller communicates down to the
model which is being observed by the
view the controls are also on things
played led this is what I'm talking
about like there is especially we look
at out the documentation and bring up
polity controller it's just it's an idea
that must developers fell in love with
not really understanding the
repercussions of it because we really
don't have a set standard of this is the
way you communicate and also when NBC
was created
great small talk are with small talk of
perfect language back in the seventies
I've been Oh back then things such as
the internet didn't exist
web browsers like NBC was meant to be
Yocum very small components like I feel
when we're developer when we were
developing out these frameworks or you
know when we had this problem we just
you know oh well let me see like give a
model neutral it just I just use that I
don't I personally don't believe that
was meant for its use case today but
that is a best to be seen so lastly
other issues that I had and this is what
react answered for me look at the way
the HTML is like it really does this is
invalid HTML when you see ng-repeat this
is a straight line framework any
frameworks it does not valid HTML at all
thank you but this doesn't this doesn't
lead so this is a home that I had a
mature covert and so internal all I see
talk about reality
in the next section know that the
standard or the best practice was to
have your HTML and in a separate file
within your JavaScript having the
tapping HTML in your JavaScript was back
you didn't do that you did that
cookie so now prep your class three
components the war that were in now
people prepare yourself I don't care if
you're tired
alright you need to get up continue
moving so plaster the components we got
react boohoo and polymer um we're gonna
talk about react not just be typical
hey Renee you know a react meetup that
has nothing to do with the fact I don't
have any experience with Google call her
either but mostly because we're gonna
react Nina right so with react it was
announced in Jenna's comp 2013 as you
see it it's underlined
you have not seen this conference or at
least the announcement of it I suggest
you do so it's like really it's crazy
whenever you see the announcement of
some of these
it's like when you do to watch the
announcement of the iPhone like it was
crazy seeing people's reaction whenever
they did the pinch-to-zoom
people lost it they're like oh my god
it's amazing right well that was the
same thing I'm in 2013 now it's normal
to us the fact that it was
groundbreaking right so reacting to
discourages mutation that renders a Dom
like a server-side render if you
remember server-side rendering rendering
has to be mentioned right like you hit
the server the server re-renders the
entire page well kind of similar to that
if you think about it right just running
on your client and code becomes more
predictable since you break everything
down and such a way to work okay it's
just the view right here we stepped away
from me you know so wow one-size-fit-all
or you know a solution for a market
problems with the full monolithic era
now we're in just with you okay I want
to decide how I'm architect my code and
so back in the J's pop 2013 this was
actual ID that was used and as Tom
Makino please say pronounce his last
name
hey Tom wookie no Donuts that this is
give me the lyrics like
I watched August talked he's really do a
very good presenter the really
interesting stuff so they said they'll
be took like huge step backwards in
terms of the main tool maintainability
of our code simply because we were
embedding markup inside of our java
scripts or remember and for that slide I
showed you before where the HTML is
separated from the JavaScript
Wells because that's what the standard
was 4years react completely just you
know made everyone rethink the way
things were done and actually had you
know people tweeting saying that what
the hell is Facebook going like what is
this this is bad and then enter tree
dumps right a flux right because it
discouraged mutation this is actually a
uh a functional of this
Redux was inspired by the architecture
which is a unique directional data flow
these are just terms whose jargon terms
it just means that like okay the whole
two-way data mining that doesn't exist
any
whatever you you take something you
change something you make an
announcement and this announcement then
goes to lay reducer and then every user
goes down to the store and the store
updates and then that causes a rear
ender right the way that the flow is
going to be the next slide this is a
unidirectional flow of data you hear the
term called pure function what that
means is you never mutate the object
that's mean that being input into the
function you always return a new object
so three types of uni directional
dataflow influence buddy I'm
architecture up and over make sure okay
and so update things like state this is
why react is so scalable right with MVC
when we had other previous frame course
minima patties you'll you'll go really
really fast building up right also you
reach a plateau and no matter what you
have the it's the so I'm pregnant what's
it is not the end man or whatever the
ghost we're like let's add people you
actually start slowing down grab the
turns on remembers but with this as as
top up keno mentioned they actually sped
up creating features because code
becomes more predictable with react and
redox or flux sure talk about your
function okay so now let's next what do
I think is next I said this is
subjective I'm an iOS developer one I
actually think so did I learn really
early on is that history repeats itself
not a one whether it's programming a
human nature history always repeats
itself right now we're talking more
crazy over these you know functional way
of programming well that existed long
time ago way before I was born so why
are we now making a big deal about it
simply do is we grab something that's
already existed and we you know wrap it
up and call us something new throw you
know an electron or neutron symbol on as
my phone couldn't you crank work right
so let's just think about like okay we
just have went to this utilities
framework you look to the MVC era and
now work the view right I personally
feel that
I think that's gonna go is gonna be data
not go but I mean what's going to be
reinvented as data I'm hoping for big
you know know that we will move away
from api's and start moving towards
WebSockets things because right now the
world is all about real-time right like
I want to get a notification online now
and guys don't really give me that
unless I do you know constant polling a
mate of my yacht so I've got WebSockets
it's gonna be the way right we're gonna
instead of updating user information
through maybe Irish we're going to send
it off the WebSocket updated right then
to an update polygon spawns so that's
one thing that I've assumed they were
gonna go as far as like who's going to
come out winnings from the component
clash of the components I think it's
gonna be react not because I'm gonna
react meet up but because coming from
the iOS space I know how much how much
work goes into just create an iOS app in
terms of life there's a reason why phone
gap of Cordoba don't work it's because
and why react has become so successful
with react native it's because react
native actually communicates down to the
JavaScript support library and it's a
library inside of iOS that allows
objective-c or Swift code to execute
JavaScript and vice versa right so
that's how reactive native in a nutshell
works so goo and polymer I got a long
way to go they had even if they even
think they're going to be competing with
react native in the future right and so
I feel that since everything's been
moving in mobile that for as a developer
I imagine in five years now a single
JavaScript developer will be able to
create applications for you know of
course the web mobile using react native
actual platforms using either react
native or something like electron so
that's where I feel like that's going
and so I mentioned like history repeats
itself right so with that you see the
effect I just think about that so the
last thing is topics and people right so
the people that I really find
influencers people that I like watching
talks over when I go on you
like you're recommended if I see Tombo
quino's name I'll stop a little Billy
and I'm watching this video really good
presenter she's a manager the react team
right the hug is also part of the
reacting have some really good
presentations especially during the 2013
2015 those presentations really good
assess whenever you know the world the
JavaScript world was really changing how
we know today
so Brandon Ikeys - the creator of
JavaScript Robert Uncle Bob Martin
this guy is a nice he's funny - he if
you want to know about architecture you
learn about things like bbm and BC MVP
harmonica fine birds and I was anything
like architecture won't start like
getting you know won't become not only a
better developer but really understand
even be able to talk to jargon Robert
humppa Bob Martin a pitcher guy john
reed you actually come from an iOS
background but most of his presentations
go over concepts like you know
architecture contested early development
he's very good and they also taught they
all talk about n be seen on the negative
now the negative like that I did they
explain I said they were on live during
creation they explain what its actual
content was lastly I think though this
property he is uh actually just our
Washington bearing mockery in his
presentation he actually kind of goes
hand in hand with Brennan I love his
thoughts are on be early days of
JavaScript this is where I learned a lot
of the you know the browser Wars and you
know what next room how that all kind of
transpired topics and like I said I'm
going to be posting this on the web for
you to you know later later click on or
later of your research on the topic you
need directional dataflow architectures
in JavaScript they had some must watch
videos from all JavaScript especially
react developers are at people shooting
why I'm sorry this is like a beautiful
of the yellow that's really hard to see
but it's gonna be the J's con 2013 and
that's been react was being announced
today also the hackers wave rethinking
web development at Facebook this
was eye-opening I remember whenever I
was applying this
Architects like reduction flux in iOS I
didn't really understand it I just knew
it was what I needed for my team so
these videos really didn't help you know
help me understand what was going on
what's up how we got to where we are
today
so last stuff I'm going to did does
anyone have any questions